je me disais si toi tu descends du sage
mois 0,1 point révélé nous un secret
vous en avez mangé du mam ou je me
trouve à fouiller en sibérie et puis un
beau matin dans le trou que j'avais
commencé à creuser je trouve que les
troupes comme ça quelque chose de
bizarre et des grands filaments je suis
étonnée je râle je dis que ce sont des
collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de fine stratégie peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis au les chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue sur arte france pour une heure
et demie d'émission comme chaque jour du
lundi au jeudi jusqu'à 21h30 place au
décryptage des grands titres de
l'actualité de la journée au programme
de ce lundi 22 novembre la guadeloupe
avec emmanuel macron qui a sur l'île de
la solidarité de la nation mais qui
dénonce des manipulations le département
qui est secoué depuis une semaine par
des violences urbaines ayant pour
origine le pass sanitaires et la colère
des soignants face à l'obligation
vaccinale dans l'union de crise a lieu
en ce moment même à matignon alors que
la grève générale illimitée commence
également dans l'île voisine de la
martinique alors embrasement aux
antilles à qui la faute on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france
les relations franco britanniques plus
que jamais en eau trouble deux mois
après le torpillage par l'australie d'un
méga contrat portant sur l'achat de
sous-marins la france au profit d'une
alliance avec le royaume uni et les
etats unis canberra signe avec
washington et londres au grand dam de
paris une officialisation ce matin alors
que les tensions de part et d'autre de
la manche reste vive au sujet de la
question migratoire au sujet d
attribution des licences de pêche
pincement exit
j moins un avant le vote final à des
députés européens sur la nouvelle
politique agricole commune une pas à
cliquer tic chez les agriculteurs
français 45 organisations membres de
l'association pour une autre paquet de
lumière c'est que choisir écrite
aujourd'hui au premier ministre jean
castex lettre ouverte pour alerter le
chef du gouvernement sur le fait que le
texte selon eux ne tient pas compte des
recommandations scientifiques et des
attentes sociales en matière
d'environnement et de climat qu'en
pensent les français focus tout à
l'heure des 21
[Musique]
réunion de crise ce soir à matignon pour
évoquer la situation chaotique en
guadeloupe après une semaine de tension
jean castex accompagné des ministres des
de la santé olivier ferrand et de
l'outre-mer sébastien lecornu accueille
les élus de l'île antillaise ou des
renforts paul de police sont dépêchés
sur place une réunion en visioconférence
puisque le chef du gouvernement est qu'à
contacter le département ultra-marin
touché de plein fouet par l'épidémie de
kobe de 19 depuis cet été est secoué
depuis une semaine par une grève
générale illimitée avec des blocages
routiers pour contester notamment
l'obligeait club l'obligation vaccinale
des soignants une grève générale qui
commence aussi sur l'île voisine de la
martinique françois xavier lambert
[Musique]
les barrages de fortune se multiplient
sur les routes de l'île il incarne la
crise sociale qui secoue la guadeloupe
depuis une semaine des blocages routiers
qui s'accompagne de violentes
manifestations
selon le gouvernement 95 personnes ont
été interpellées après des incendies et
des pillages même si la plupart des
manifestants ne se livre pas à ces
violences tous dénoncent la mise en
place de la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants et cela en tant qu'homme
soignants en tant qu individu qui
revendique le droit de faire au choix de
ce qu'ils feront comme médicament qui
fait un doigt qui revendique le droit de
faire ce qu'elles veulent or c'est un
sentiment de dégoût c'est un sentiment
non mais aussi parce que avec ce qu'on a
subi cette année on n'allait pas de
vendre sa la nuit dernière a pourtant
été plus calme sur l'île
malgré quelques voitures brûlées le
couvre-feu a dans l'ensemble été
respectée une légère accalmie liées à la
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre selon
la préfecture pour faire face à la crise
le ministre de l'outre-mer sébastien
lecornu a confirmé l'envoi en guadeloupe
de 50 policiers et militaires du raid et
du gign de son côté le chef de l'état en
déplacement à amiens rassuré que la
nation entière et est solidaire avec la
guadeloupe il y à une situation qui est
très explosive qui est liée à un
contexte très local la détention qu'on
connaît et qui sont historiques et aussi
à certains intérêts qui cherchent un peu
à utiliser ce contexte et l'anxiété la
nation est en solidarité l'union
générale des travailleurs de guadeloupe
qui porte cette contestation a appelé à
poursuivre le mouvement et la
contestation semble devoir s'étendre à
l'autre grande île des antilles
françaises
les syndicats martiniquais ont appelé à
la grève générale elle a commencé ce
lundi
[Musique]
éloigné de la métropole et dom tom
subissent de nombreuses difficultés
notamment économiques et sociales la
crise sanitaire n'a pas arrangé les
choses alors les territoires d'outre-mer
sont-ils délaissé y at-il un risque
d'embrasement si oui à qui la faute en
attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme daté france tout de suite
parce décryptage
[Musique]
et pour parler de tout ça nos invités le
secrétaire général
monsieur daniel dalin secrétaire général
du cre et femmes bonjour le président du
rrq réforme le donc le conseil
représentatif des français d'outre-mer
bonsoir pour soi et puis en direct de
fort-de-france à nous critiquer ayotte
présidente de l'ue rml l'union régionale
des médecins libéraux de martinique
bonsoir ou plutôt bonjour comme le
décalage horaire je commence avec vous à
une crique alliotte puisque vous êtes
sur place comment est la situation du
côté de fort de france ce soir
alors moi je suis médecin donc je suis
président de l'union régionale des
médecins libéraux donc je vous parlais
de médecine et je vais vous annoncer
quand même des bonnes nouvelles en cette
période troublée pour vous annoncer que
quand même le 4 juillet nous avions 8 %
de la population qui avait un schéma
vaccinal complet aujourd'hui nous avons
39 6% de la population qui a schéma
vaccinal complet donc enfin kia qui a
pardon c'était qu'il ya une première
tous 15% actuellement nous sommes à
42,5 pour cent de la population qui a eu
une première dose donc vous voyez on a
une augmentation de la vaccination au
sein de la population donc 300 personnes
quand même se font vacciner tous les
jours donc pour nous c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais a commencé chez vous
je vous parle de médecine moi je suis
médecin si vous voulez asociaux leurs
intérêts interviewé à la sociologue nous
notre message médical et de faire passer
que la vaccination permet d'échapper aux
cas graves d'échapper à une
hospitalisation et c'est pour préserver
la santé de la population martiniquaise
donc le message commence à passer du
côté de la martinique daniel dalin
comment est-ce que vous expliquer la
situation exclusif qui a lieu en
guadeloupe depuis maintenant une semaine
et comment est ce que la population
ça
pour cela il faudrait d'abord rappelé le
contexte nous les outre-mers jeudi nous
les outre mers parce que je suis
originaire de la martinique mais en tant
que président du crif hommes liges et
une vision ainsi globale de ce qui se
passe en outre-mer dans les autres mers
il y à un traître alors je ne suis pas
là pour vous pour dire que nous sommes
discriminer tout ça on n'est pas dans
cette rue cas on dit simplement que
depuis des années depuis 2009 lors de la
dernière la dernière grogne avait duré
44 jours
la montagne a accouché d'une souris
c'est à dire que des promesses faites
n'ont pas été tenues
cette espèce de
d'impression que tout vient de manière
verticale de là vous vous avez dit dans
la métropole moi je dis tout vient de
l'hexagone et et ça descend vers vers la
martinique vers la guadeloupe vers les
autres maires et souvent ce sont des
décisions qui sont pas applicables
dans le contexte local on voit que les
décisions de ceux qui prennent les
décisions sont totalement ignorants du
contexte local alors ça plus les crises
les crises sanitaires que successives
que ce soit la dernière crise sanitaire
que nous avons nous sommes entrés qui
est comme madame est médecin a peut-être
ne le me le dire nous avons une
problématique avec les alliances et les
agace si vous allez en martinique et en
guadeloupe vous n'oubliez des endroits
où vous ne pouvez pas rester parce que
c'est pas bon on sait qu'ils arrivent à
avoir un problème sanitaire sur le long
terme nous avons un problème sanitaire
nous avons eu un problème sanitaire en
gros c'est la défiance vis-à-vis
totalement la défiance nous avons un
problème sanitaire avec la problématique
de chlordécone madame pourra dire un
beau ciel veut mais sachez simplement
que la martinique et la guadeloupe nos
deux départements ont été pendant des
décennies
totalement livré à la la la à la
distribution des de la chlordécone dans
les terres à tel point que la mer les
côtes les cotes de les trucs côtier
côtiers les rivières tout ce que vous
voulez c'est pollué par la chlordécone
et la chlordécone
et à peu près j'ai entendu 200 ou 300
ans pour disparaître naturellement at il
y at il un plan pour nettoyer mi sol on
n'en sait rien mais tout ce qu'on sait
c'est que le département sont les
champions du monde de cancer de la
prostate et des maladies chez les femmes
aussi voilà dans le petit les dom tom
sont les sont les grands oubliés mais
justement qu'est ce que vous attendez de
ce nom c'est pas les soirs il ya quand
même une réunion à matignon avec les
élus
locaux et le premier ministre on a dit
jean castex illescas contact mais ce
sera donc par visioconférence a
également ministre de la santé il ya le
ministre de l'outre-mer qu'est ce que
vous attendez de c'est la grand messe il
ya des élus c'est au lit aux élus locaux
de faire aspirer de faire de porter les
revendications des populations seulement
je fais remarquer que beaucoup la parole
des élus de manière générale elle a été
décrédibilisée
ll est décrédibilisé parce que à force
de demander des choses à paris très peu
de choses en été il ya eu droit ya eu
très peu de retour à un moment donné la
population jugent les élus par rapport à
leur capacité de faire évoluer leur lot
problématique or je dis que si le
gouvernement veut vraiment je veux
vraiment sortir la martinique et la
guadeloupe et l'outre-mer de l'ornière
il faut vraiment mettre des gens qui
connaissent la problématique des autres
maires à des postes pour traiter la
problématique parce que qui mieux qu'un
ultra marins pourraient pourrez vous
êtes en train de dire c'est pas les
bonnes personnes qui est son jeu pasqua
se lasse pas je pense que ce ne sont pas
les bonnes personnes pour certaines ce
ne sont pas les bonnes personnes
anna cagnotte oui allez-y
je voudrais réagir un petit peu sur sur
ce qu'il dit je voudrais quand même
rappeler que nous faisons face en
martinique en guadeloupe à une femme a à
une vague c'est un tsunami jeu 7 101
décès ont été à déplorer au chu de
martinique par rapport à la population
martiniquaise qui est de 360 milles
patience à
habitants si on se réfère aux nombreux
si on fait cette prospection vis-à-vis
du chiffre au niveau national ça
voudrait dire qu'on à 127 milles morts
donc c'est énorme on aurait eu cent
vingt-sept mille morts
j'insiste d'autant plus que dans les
chiffres ce ne sont que les chiffres de
l'hôpital et on a 600 morts qui sont
donc les chiffres de l'insee sont tombés
avant-hier ça veut dire qu'on a eu 600
décès supplémentaires dus qu'aux vide
donc nous vous avons nous nous avons
donc mais de son décès
ça veut dire que par rapport à la koala
la population française hexagonal nous
serions à 10 ans à 2 118 mille morts
pour la métropole actuellement je
rappelle que la pandémie en hexagone a
fait en faire en tout en france a fait
116 morts donc nous faisons face à une
hécatombe donc en tant que médecins nous
devons la plusieurs problèmes sont
intriqués monsieur parlait des sargasses
de la chlordécone il ya des plan
chlordécone ya préfet qui était nommé
pour les sargasses au niveau de l'union
régionale des médecins ont lancé un
appel il ya des crédits qui sont fléchi
pour le feder pour justement traiter de
ces problématiques je pense qu'il faut
pas tout confondre
ce qui a mis je peux pas annoncer leur
mariage
pour l'hôpital
c'est un report du pam vaccinale qui est
fait pour l'hôpital avec une mise en
tension parce que l'hôpital est toujours
en train de faire face à cette quatrième
vague de co vide les équipes sont
surmenés sont surchargés elles ont à
elles ont du mal à faire face
les libéraux sont six à bout et il faut
face aux nombreux décès aux familles qui
sont attristés et andouillé donc moi mon
rôle de médecin c'est de préparer la
population c'est d'appeler à la
vaccination en vain et de prévenir on a
300 patients qui se font pas que trois
cents 300 martiniquais qui se font
vacciner tous les jours les chiffres
montrent un je vous rappel de 8 % une
seule de vaccination complète on est
passé à 39 est de 15% de deux doses avec
une vaccination
on arrive aujourd'hui on explose donc
les chiffres sont à 40 % donc il faut
redonner cette confiance il faut ré
engager la main sur
nationale dans la fonction il gagne bien
parler de parler de défiance justement
vous avez voté
répondre à madame lui dire que déjà dans
un premier temps personnellement je suis
fonctionnaire de santé personnels de
santé j'ai je n'ai pas honte de dire que
j'ai reçu mes trois doses donc pour vous
dire que je crois au bénéfice de la
vaccination c'est pas là le souci c'est
pas le problème jeudi je trace le
contexte général le contexte général qui
veut que nos populations sont des
fientes par rapport aux directives qui
viennent de métropole comme la plus
forte des finances justement qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire par exemple il ya
fabien roussel candidat pcf à l'élection
présidentielle qui va se rendre aux
antilles prochainement et qui a déclaré
qu'il appelle un plan d'urgence pour les
outremers un peu comme ce qui s'est fait
à marseille est ce que ce serait selon
vous une solution nous ce qu'on dit ce
que je dis pour je suis martiniquais je
suis je connais la problématique je dis
simplement il faut mettre les bonnes
personnes aux bons postes ça c'est un
premier point deuxième point il faut que
l'état il faut que l'état
il ya eu les états généraux d'outre-mer
en 2009 rappelez vous il ya eu les états
généraux de l'outre-mer nicolas sarkozy
qui est qui qui était le président de la
république c'est pas quelqu'un c'est pas
mon bord politique c'est pas ma famille
politique mais nicolas sarkozy avait
créé avait eu l'intelligence de créer la
délégation interministérielle en charge
de l'égalité des chances des français
d'outre-mer le président nicolas sarkozy
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
politiquement parlant il avait compris
qu'il y avait une différence de
traitement entre les délais mais les
départements d'outre-mer qui sont là bas
et même si quelques-uns des ultramarins
qui sont ici dans l'hexagone il avait
créé sa cette délégation aurait pu faire
un travail formidable formidable
seulement là françois hollande est
passée par là ensuite et maintenant le
délégué interministériel
c'est simplement le collabo l'un des
collaborateurs du ministre et outre mer
parce que maintenant il n'est plus sous
l'autorité directe du premier ministre
je veux vous compreniez la logique si
vous voulez sortir les antilles de leur
ornière il faut leur donner la
possibilité la capacité de sortir parce
que nous pouvons sortir annuel macron
peut comprendre il ya par exemple il ya
beaucoup de politiques ont réagi il ya
par exemple jordan bardella le président
par intérim indus et rennes qui a
déclaré emmanuel macron n'a pas compris
les jets les jeunes donc difficile de
comprendre une france qui vit à dix
mille kilomètres de là moi je dis pas ça
je pense que le président de la
république il a eu à gérer une crise qui
est compliqué elle est vraiment
compliqué la crise il n'y a pas un pays
pour ce qui peut on peut dire qu'il ya
un pays qui s'en est sorti et qui
rendait à tourner la page aucun pays
c'est compliqué pour lui la seule chose
que je dis aussi si que je pense qu'il
n'est pas souvent bien entouré parce que
c'est qu'on a l'impression que c'est
toujours les mêmes choses qui reviennent
à l'est comme le tonneau des dardanelles
ça revient tout le temps tout en tout le
temps et à force de crier qui vous
faites allusion
à qui je fais allusion on a fait la loi
par exemple la loi égalité réelle en
outre-mer la loi égalité en outre-mer ça
a servi à quoi à rien madame qui est
médecin pourra me pourra le dire aussi
bien souvent nous avons alerté celui qui
est maintenant sénateur ancien ministre
et outre-mer victorin lurel il avait
dénoncé l' apport de sucres et de sel
supplémentaires dans les années dans
l'alimentation qui partait en direction
de ceux des autres maires le sucre et le
sel c'est diabète c'est cholestérol
c'est tout c'est tous ces problématiques
en france on en fait une cause nationale
on fait des jours aux antilles en
envoient des aliments avec 10 % et 3 %
de sucre et de sel en plus voyez bien
qu'il ya un traitement selon qu'on soit
en france et selon qu'on sera en
martinique ou en guadeloupe et je ne
parle même pas de mayotte crier à
mayotte ils sont restés pendant tout
l'été sans eau en guadeloupe ils font
des tours il ya c'est la crise sanitaire
il faut le respecter les gestes barrière
il n'y a pas d'eau voyez mais on vient
nous parler de pas sanitaire
l'obligation vaccinale moi je dis à mes
compatriotes vaccinez vous mais s'ils
veulent pas se vacciner est ce que pour
autant jeu
je vais mettre des familles dans la
misère on les en les licenciant non je
pense que c'est à force de discuter je
pense que c'est à force de de parler
d'expliquer aux gens qu'à la création
d'un tissu table-ronde de ce soit
comme ça encore de déclarations la
réunion a lieu en ce moment à les ir le
mot de la fin en critérium
hyper rebondir il est évident que dans
les drom nous avons des spécificités qui
doivent être prises en compte par
l'hexagone c'est une évidence et je
rejoins totalement monsieur d'alain nous
devons avoir des spécificités qui soient
prises en compte et avoir des gens qui
connaissent bien le terrain mais je
pense qu'on peut compter sur nos élus et
il faut que ça soit remonté que le
gouvernement son tour ce qui faire et
quand le président macro est venu il a
rencontré les élus il a bien pris en
compte la problématique chlordécone
dettes des états qui ont été faits sur
des états généraux sur la chlordécone
gains plan chlordécone kiev qui est
lancée mais nous avons beaucoup de
sujets et sur lequel des spécificités
outre-mer doivent être prises en compte
nous sommes à du 1000 km avec des
difficultés d'approvisionnement en ce
moment il y avait des gros problèmes
d'approvisionnement et bien évidemment
tout ceci doit être prise en compte nous
avons point de vue médical da un taux
d'incidence beaucoup plus importants du
diavel du glaucome de l'insuffisance
rénale du surpoids et de l'obésité des
spécificités sur lequel nous n'avons pas
forcément les moyens d'agir dont je vous
rejoins totalement merci où vous vous
rejoignez là dessus et vous êtes donc
d'accord pour dire que là en fait vous
appelez plus à un traitement de fond
de la guadeloupe de la martinique plutôt
que de la réunion qui a lieu en ce
moment mes amis qui seul est donc des
violences urbaines qui ont lieu en ce
moment c'est là c'est la fin de deux
très rapidement très rapidement le
mouvement des filets jaunes leur aide ni
le jdn ni leur aide ont participé à au
maintien des forces de l'ordre le
mouvement des gilet jaune avec tout ce
que ça a pu créer
l'arc de triomphe et toula ya eu quand
même beaucoup beaucoup de
style et je loupe on nous envoie le gign
et il serait temps de membres
dans ce sont
les terroristes nous ne sommes pas des
terroristes nous sommes une population
qui est en souffrance nous sommes en
cause une population qui y est comment
dirais-je résiliente mais qui a besoin
aussi de respect tout simplement est
bien le mot est passé merci beaucoup
d'années le talent d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes donc
le président du crif le conseil
représentatif des français d'outre-mer
merci également à vous and cry cry ou
d'avoir répondu à une question vous êtes
président de l'union régionale des
médecins libéraux de martinique
et le gouvernement prévoit donc de ne
pas fléchir face à l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants aux antilles
motif les chiffres du comité qui ne
cesse d'augmenter l'hexagone est
confrontée à une cinquième vague
fulgurante selon la rhétorique de
gabrielat talent porte parole du
gouvernement ce week-end en une semaine
et cas de contamination presque doublé
conséquence les mesures de restriction
sont renforcés aux frontières tout
voyageur non vaccinés en provenance de
luxembourg de la pologne ou encore de la
suisse devra présenter un test négatif
de moins de 24 heures au lieu de 72
heures précédemment
outre-rhin le ministre allemand de la
santé prévient d'ici la fin de l'hiver
ses concitoyens seront je cite vacciner
guéri ou mort pour angela merkel la
situation est dramatique
pour la chancelière les restrictions
actuelles ne sont plus suffisantes et
les règles sanitaires se durcissent
aussi en autriche voisine à nouveau mis
sous cloche depuis ce matin la
vaccination de la population adulte
autrichienne va également devenir
obligatoire au 1er février prochain
thibault janin
des rues quasiment vides et des magasins
fermés un nouveau décor pour les
autrichiens sous le coup de leur
quatrième confinement depuis le début de
la crise une mesure forte prévu jusqu'au
13 décembre que les autorités ont
annoncé après une multiplication des cas
de kobe de 19 dans le pays al'approche
des fêtes de fin d'année elle est loin
de plaire à tout le monde bien sûr je
suis agacé j'étais déjà dans l'ambiance
de noël et j'aurais adoré aller au
marché de noël mais ce n'est pas
possible nous ne pouvons pas changer la
décision de toute façon nous ne pouvons
que suivre les règles et en tirer le
meilleur parti
je suis vraiment agacé par ce qu'on
aurait dû faire plus de recherche cet
été
on aurait dû mettre en place une
vaccination obligatoire en été
66% des autrichiens ont reçu deux doses
contre 75 % en france résultat à la
vaccination de la population adulte va
devenir obligatoire dès le 1er février
2022 des annonces tombée comme un
couperet pour certains samedi ils
étaient environ 40000 dans les rues de
vienne pour dénoncer ces mesures
d'autres manifestations ont eu lieu dans
le pays comme à linz dans le nord de
l'autriche où des milliers de
protestataires se sont rassemblés
dimanche
autres manifestations ailleurs en europe
ce week-end troisième nuit consécutive
de violences au pays bas où le premier
ministre mark rutte a dénoncé tout à
l'heure une violence pure de la part d'
idiot
colère aussi en belgique où des dizaines
de milliers de manifestants ont protesté
ce week-end contre les règles sanitaires
des rassemblement émaillé de violences
notamment à bruxelles violence
absolument inacceptable d'après le chef
du gouvernement a plus de précision avec
ce sujet signé et grégoire doucet
la pilule a bien du mal à passer les
mesures imposées par le gouvernement
face à la recrudescence de l'épidémie ne
sont pas du goût de milliers de belges
ils étaient 35 mille selon la police
dans les rues de bruxelles ce dimanche
pour dire non à la généralisation du
masque en intérieur au télétravail
imposé ou encore au retour des jauges
restrictives pour de nombreux événements
il ne s'agit plus de politique il s'agit
de dominer les gens comme des animaux
désormais on veut juste dominés les gens
c'est ce qui est en train d'arriver ni
plus ni moins mais nous ne l'accepterons
pas comme vous le montre des centaines
de personnes
mercredi dernier le premier ministre
alexander de croo avait pourtant appelé
la population à rester soudée
si nous voulons éviter un confinement
nous devons tous prendre nos
responsabilités et nous ne sommes pas
les uns contre les autres ce ne sont pas
les entreprises contre les écoles ou
contre le secteur culturel ce ne sont
pas les jeunes contre les personnes
âgées les contradictions nous aiderons
aucunement nous allons devoir le faire
ensemble
ce sont au contraire des scènes de
divisions qui ont émaillé la capitale
belge les forces de l'ordre ont utilisé
les canons à eau en réponse aux jets de
projectiles deux policiers ont été
blessés pour l'infectiologue ils vendent
les thèmes ce ras-le-bol et compréhensif
mais ne rend pas les restrictions -
nécessaire je pense qu'elles sont
victimes en regrettable que son témoin
que la population un peu partout dans le
monde en europe de l'ouest comme
ailleurs on a un petit peu marre
effectivement de cette situation qui
dure qui dure depuis un an et demi et
que ne comprend plus bien la finalité
des mesures qui sont encore nécessaires
et malheureusement ces mesures en plus
la vaccination sont encore nécessaires
au cours de la semaine écoulée
la belgique a recensé en moyenne plus de
13 mille cas quotidiens d'infection au
covic 19
à les relations franco britanniques que
jamais en eaux troubles deux mois après
le torpillage par l'australie d'un méga
contrat portant sur l'achat de
sous-marins
france au profit d'une alliance entre le
royaume uni et les etats unis qu'on
verra signe avec washington et londres
au grand dam de paris une
officialisation ce matin alors que les
tensions de part et d'autre de la manche
reste vive au sujet de la question
migratoire et d attribution des licences
des pêches poste par exit le point
là-dessus avec thibaut jana
une rencontre pour calmer les esprits
c'est ce qu'a entrepris la ministre de
la mer ce dimanche annick girardin s'est
rendu dans les hauts de france pour
discuter avec les pêcheurs mécontents et
les rassurer sur son intention de
continuer le combat une longue bataille
engagée contre londres sur les licences
post briggs hier c'est inadmissible
l'interprétation que font les anglais de
nos dossiers et inadmissibles et ne
répond pas à la bonne volonté de la
france et de l'ensemble des
professionnels qui met sur la table la
totalité de leurs dossiers avec
l'ensemble des explications nous nous
battons au quotidien pour ces marins
pour ces bateaux pour ses licences et
ans lâchera rien du tout un soutien
affiché mais pas suffisant pour rassurer
totalement les professionnels de la
pêche les pêcheurs vont bouger je crois
qu'ils ont été suffisamment patient ça
fait quand même 11 mois qu'ils attendent
là on arrive en période de fin d'année
où il ya une forte demande de crustacés
etc et nos petits bateaux ne peuvent pas
aller dans les eaux britanniques pêcher
le cloud saas et comme ils font depuis
des générations je pense que s'il ya des
actions ça sera vraiment très ciblée
voilà tout simplement
ça sensible et
serpents pour emmerder anonyme que ce
soit notre notre économie ou n'importe
quoi ça sera plutôt pour emmerder
l'économie anglaise des actions
envisagées alors que paris peine à
obtenir des droits de pêche notamment
auprès de l'île de jersey dans le même
temps les négociations entre bruxelles
et londres patine jeudi annick girardin
avait évoquée l'indemnisation possible
des professionnels qui se retrouveraient
sans licence un aveu d'échec selon les
pêcheurs al'approche des fêtes de fin
d'année période cruciale pour les
pêcheurs et près d'un an après
l'officialisation du bric site 150
bateaux sont toujours dans l'attenté
d'une autorisation
pour pouvoir pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques
960 licences attribuées selon annick
girardin la ministre française de la mer
qui indique que 80 % des dossiers sont
finalisés à ce donc environ 150 bateaux
toujours inquiets onze mois après le
brésil une attente devenu pour certains
insupportable on en parle avec aymeric
jeanneau secrétaire général du syndicat
des mareyeurs boulonnais
bonsoir américiane merci de répondre à
nos questions ce soir au ces assises de
la pêche et de la mer le week end mais
certains ont dénoncé le site le naufrage
de la france et de l'union européenne
vous avez le sentiment d'être pris entre
les filets d'une crise politique et
diplomatique qui vous dépasse
pas tout à fait alors effectivement aux
assises de la pêche et quelques annonces
qui était particulièrement malvenue a
notamment ses histoires de hand sortie
de flotte et heureusement heureusement
madame la ministre est venu rassurer les
marins pêcheurs à rassurer l'ensemble de
la filière dimanche dernier à
boulogne-sur-mer en indiquant qu
effectivement le plan de sortie de
flotte était uniquement un outil parmi
d'autres et qui pourraient
éventuellement être utilisé pour les
quelques et quelques bateaux qu'ils
n'obtiendraient pas gain de cause en
matière de licence mais les mots a été
lâché dès est vraiment rassuré quand
même est-ce que c'est pas un
rétropédalage jouent gaiement
partiellement rassuré bon effectivement
un certain nombre d' annonces ont été
faites un certain nombre de procédures
sont lancées obtenir maintenant très
rapidement les quelques dizaines de
licence qui lui manque un sur le
littoral de france et une trentaine de
licences et dans la région c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement important
puisque si vous regardez un petit peu le
positionnement géographique on est
située juste en face du royaume uni et
la manche est partagée pour moitié du
côté britannique et du côté français
donc nos pêcheries sont effectivement
extrêmement exposées et le mariage que
je représente qui est la première place
en france pour le mariage est
extrêmement dépendante à la fois des
apports de pêche britanniques mais
également
des produits de la pêche de nos
flottille dans les eaux britanniques
donc il est indispensable que l'on
puisse mettre un peu plus la pression
pour que l'on sorte enfin de ce dossier
justement mettre un peu plus la pression
ça veut dire quoi annick girardin
emmanuel macron promettent de continuer
le combat selon vous le gouvernement
français fait il réellement de son mieux
sk
un langage de communication quelle marge
de manoeuvre
paris dispose selon vous pour faire
plier londres mais un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été qui ont été
annoncées de manière
relativement imprécise bon jusqu'à
présent la pression s'est fait
relativement discrète aurions nous dira
un même si une dizaine de licences et
été obtenus depuis les annonces ou les
promesses de rétorsion là je pense que
manifestement les uns et les autres vont
passer à la vitesse supérieure autre
élément important c'est que l'europe est
rentré dans le jeu je pense que c'est un
élément essentiel
il fallait pas rester isolé face royaume
uni il est important que l'union
européenne soit au côté la france sa
filière pour pouvoir faire la pression
sur eux sur les britanniques il faut pas
oublier c'est que les britanniques sont
son gros producteur un sombre aux
pêcheurs mais sont très peu de
consommateurs dont ils ont absolument
besoin
du marché européen et en particulier du
marché français qui consomment
énormément de produits de la mer alors
ce qui va être délicat c'est
effectivement de pouvoir augmenter le
niveau de pression sur sur le royaume
uni tout en préservant notre notre
activité sur boulogne-sur-mer qui est la
première place de marché en france pour
les produits de la mer bon ben ya un
certain nombre de choses qui ont été
évoqués ils vont sans doute se met en
place la très très prochainement et
j'ose espérer que les uns comme les
autres seront très rapidement recouvrer
la raison pour qu'on sorte enfin de ce
dossier qui n'a que trop duré puisque
l'ensemble de ces licences devait
accorder depuis la fin janvier voire le
début février ça fait quand même un an
que ça dure et concrètement sur le
terrain ça se traduit comment au niveau
des têtes quels sont les états d'esprit
de vos confrères est-ce qu'ils souffrent
également ce qui en a qui pourraient
déposer le bilan ce que les
professionnels de la filière française
ont des fins de mois plus difficiles
en matière en matière de pêcheurs où il
ya des situations qui sont qui sont
extrêmement délicate en ce qui concerne
l'aval de la filière et les marieurs ça
dépend un petit peu du positionnement de
la spécialité de l'entreprise mais on a
quand même subi
des arrêts des arrêts temporaires de nos
bateaux si vous voulez quand vous avez
la moitié de vos qui vous est finalement
interdit à vous êtes obligés de gérer
les quotas de gérer la pression de pêche
et nous avons depuis le début de l'année
ben des arrêts des bateaux par
intermittence et quand votre métier et
travail et du poisson et qu'on rapporte
moins de poissons forcément ça pose un
problème alors on est on est sur des
baisses d'activité pour les entreprises
les plus touchées qui sont de l'ordre de
20% et d'un pour cent c'est quelque
chose extrêmement accord ça ne peut pas
durer il faut absolument qu'on puisse
recouvrer une situation normale
merci beaucoup et aymeric tienne d'avoir
répondu à nos questions de nous avoir
éclairé sur votre situation je rappelle
que vous êtes le secrétaire général du
syndicat des mareyeurs boulonnais
sa pêche donc dans les relations franco
britanniques mais outre la pêche il ya
aussi la faire des sous marins avec la
signature officielle de londres avec
canberra et washington au grand dam de
parier qui perd 56 milliards d'euros
dans la balance et il ya un diamant
l'immigration illégale par la manche
france royaume-uni je t'aime moi non
plus on en parle avec l'autre
blanchemaison notre expert en relations
internationales
bonsoir claude merci d'être d'être là
avec nous ce soir
la première question avec donc paris qui
a accusé de céder face au gouvernement
britannique on l'a vu avec cette
interview d'aymeric chan la difficulté
des marins des marins pêcheurs paris
assuré qu'il ne lâcherait rien mais de
quelle marge de manoeuvre dispose encore
à la france pour essayer de faire bouger
les choses très fin parce que d'une part
le gouvernement britannique veut
justifier le break site en adoptant une
attitude intransigeante et puis parce
que d'autre part il faut bien dire nous
sommes à cinq points des élections
présidentielles et je dirais même que
jusqu'au 4 décembre prochain la marge de
manoeuvre est probable est probablement
égal à zéro on a vu hier le débat des
candidats
pour fins de ceux qui voudraient aux
primaires des eunuques du parti et l'air
devenir le candidat abdou les verts à la
présidentielle
et on voit bien que les 3 que trois
candidats sont en embuscade pour pointer
la responsabilité éventuelle de de
monsieur barnier barnier a été le
négociateur du traité break site ils
l'ont d'ailleurs félicité d'avoir très
bien négocié mais chacun sait que s'il
ya des problèmes sur ce sujet comme
d'ailleurs sur demande du nord c'est que
ce sujet était finalement mal ficelé mal
ficelé pourquoi parce qu'il existait à
traiter de granville signé en 2000 il y
a 20 ans qui inscrivait un traité
bilatéral entre la france et la
grande-bretagne et dans ce traité on
inscrivait les droits traditionnels des
pêcheurs artisanaux ceux qui ne peuvent
pas enregistrer leur parcours et c'est
bien cela que les britanniques
aujourd'hui refusent de délivrer des
licences vous ne pouvez pas démontré que
vous êtes des pêcheurs traditionnels par
conséquent vous n'aurez pas de licence
et c'est un dialogue de sourds si on
avait repris la convention de grands
vivent dans le traité des briques site
ce problème là n'existait pas alors
peut-être que les juristes de la
commission européenne peut-être que les
juristes de londres considéré que cette
convention devait être caduque et
qu'elles devaient être supprimés à
l'occasion des briques site mais le
problème demeure en réalité
que ce sont les pêcheurs traditionnels
les pêcheurs artisanaux de petits
bateaux qui n'ont pas d'équipement
électronique à qui on refuse des
licences de pêche et ça risque de durer
encore longtemps parce que ils sont
aussi pris en otage maintenant dans la
campagne présidentielle française est
évidemment personne ne veut être vu
comme étant celui qui a fait un
compromis le compromis ça veut dire que
on n'aura pas raison à 100 % bien sûr
tous les tyrans la compresser londres
qu'à l'ascendant dans ce dossier est les
français qui ont essuyé aussi un échec
un revers
avec le bois septembre dernier la sphère
des sous-marins la signature ce matin
puisque l'australie s'est engagée dans
sa nouvelle alliance s'est concrétisée
avec les etats-unis et le royaume-uni
donc alors la photo montre en effet le
ministre de la défense australien qui
signe avec le chargé d'affaires
américain parce qu'il ya pas encore
d'ambassadeur depuis l'élection de
monsieur nigel et avec la haute
commissaire britannique puisque à
l'intérieur du commonwealth bien les
ambassadeurs sont appelés aux
commissaires bon mais c'est un accord
technique c'est un accord technique qui
permet les échanges d'informations sur
la propulsion nucléaire en milieu marin
il y en aura beaucoup d'autres
désaccords bien sûr parce que il faudra
les accords sur la construction des sous
marins sur la livraison de l'uranium
enrichi qui permettra de faire la
propulsion nucléaire de ces sous-marins
est donc là on est simplement au tout
début d'un processus et effectivement
je pense que là dessus la grande
bretagne a joué un intermédiaire utile
entre les états unis et l'australie
l'australie rêvait d'être sous la
protection américaine et bien maintenant
il ya une alliance militaire entre
l'australie les etats-unis et le
royaume-uni de grande-bretagne
c'est très exactement la conception
qu'ont les états unis de ce qu'ils
appellent la stratégie indo pacifique ce
n'est pas la nôtre ça n'est pas celle de
l'inde ça n'est pas celle des pays
d'asie du sud-est qui considère que
l'ado pacifique c'est autre chose ce
sont les coopérations très diversifiée
entre les pays qui en effet on comme
intérêt majeur d'assurer la liberté de
circulation maritime dans les détroits
notamment le détroit de malacca mais il
y en a beaucoup d'autres de façon à
assurer les approvisionnements dans les
deux sens approvisionnements de l'asie
en matière première approvisionnements
de l'europe en produits en produits
fabriqués et là effectivement on a une
divergence profonde
je crois que dans l'avenir on verra que
la stratégie au pacifique va soulever de
réelles difficultés puisque on n'y met
pas les mêmes réalités donc désaccord
entre paris et londres sur la pêche on
l'a vu au niveau diplomatique avec la
sphère des sous-marins et puis il ya
également la question migratoire avec
l'immigration clandestine entre la
france et le royaume uni via la manche
alors c'est une question évidemment très
très importante il ya énormément de
migrants qui arrivent dans la région de
calais et qui ont comme seul objectif de
parvenir au royaume-uni de
grande-bretagne ce qui pose d'ailleurs
une première question sait d'où vient à
cette activité cette attractivité de la
grille du royaume en grande bretagne
pour attirer tous ces migrants il ya
bien entendu le problème du regroupement
familial ils ont peut-être déjà d'aider
des parents qui sont en grande bretagne
il ya le problème de la langue la plus
quelques uns parlent anglais c'est plus
commode pour eux mais aussi
l'attractivité
que le royaume uni propage en créant des
emplois qui sont les emplois précaires
des emplois à bon marché si j'ose dire
mais les emplois qu'on mêle et qui donne
droit à l'accès aux soins grande
bretagne cet ensemble de choses fait qu'
il y a en effet une attractivité pour
les migrants et que peut-être que la
grande bretagne devrait revoir ce
problème est peut-être modifier les
conditions dans lesquelles les migrants
peuvent bénéficier des avantages qu'ils
pensent avoir mis le croit avoir en
arrivant en grande bretagne qui sont
d'ailleurs largement illusoire dans le
domaine social et dans le domaine de
l'emploi puisque ce sont les emplois
très précaire quelquefois quelques
heures par semaine mais bon ils sont
attirés par ce miroir aux alouettes de
l'économie britannique libéré des
contraintes de l'union européenne qui
peut créer des emplois comme elle
l'entend merci claude blanche maison
pour votre analyse est votre décryptage
rappelle que vous êtes notre expert en
relations internationales
des centaines de migrants ont toujours
la question migratoire des centaines de
microns de bloquer à la frontière entre
la pologne et la biélorussie
alors que les occidentaux reproche
kaminski et d'avoir orchestré cette
crise migratoire les autorités
biélorusses accuse aujourd'hui l'union
européenne de refuser tout dialogue le
président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko s'est exprimé tout à leur
dos j'attends que l'union européenne
répondent à la question concernant les
deux mille réfugiés nous avons environ
2000 réfugiés dans ce campement je leur
ai demandé de les prendre à serge
thomann zabadani ce que
la chancelière allemande m'a promis
qu'ils allaient examiner ce problème au
niveau européen
ils ne l'envisagent mais
il même les personnes qui a indiqué ne
prendra contact avec nous
nous allons occuper de ces personnes ou
même si l'allemagne ne les accueille pas
mais que pouvons nous faire d'autre part
où il part ou les abonnés nous devons
réclamer aux allemands qu'il les
accueille
soignez vous à minsk a assuré la semaine
dernière que la chancelière allemande
allait négocier avec l'union européenne
la mise en place d'un couloir
humanitaire pour évacuer les 2000
migrants restants vers l'allemagne une
annonce fermement démenti tout à l'heure
par berlin
l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir un couloir
humanitaire vers l'allemagne pour
accueillir 2000 migrants n'est pas une
solution acceptable pour l'allemagne où
l'union européenne nous l'avons déjà dit
la semaine dernière et le ministre de
l'intérieur seehofer l'a également
déclaré lorsqu'il a rendu visite à son
homologue polonais la semaine dernière
et ce week-end varsovie a qualifié cette
crise migratoire je cite de plus grande
tentative de déstabilisation de l'europe
depuis la guerre froide
la pologne fera tout pour défendre les
frontières de l'union européenne selon
la rhétorique hier du premier ministre
polonais et ce alors que varsovie et est
soupçonné par bruxelles de cristalliser
les attentions sur cette crise pour
cacher le non respect de certains de ses
engagements vis-à-vis de lui les
tensions sont toujours vives entre les
deux parties c'est pour tenter
d'atténuer ces frictions que le chef du
gouvernement polonais entame aujourd'hui
une tournée européenne quentin mauclair
une tournée dans des pays baltes pour
allier les 27 à sa cause le premier
ministre polonais mateusz m'ont radié ce
qui s'est rendu en estonie en lettonie
et en lituanie ce dimanche sujet central
des entrevues la crise migratoire à la
frontière avec la biélorussie
le chef du gouvernement appelle les 27 à
soutenir la position polonaise
unis en europe et au cours des derniers
mois la biélorussie a renforcé ses
actions contre l'union européenne et
pour nous il est important de comprendre
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un conflit
artificiel avec la pologne ou la
lituanie
il s'agit d'une tentative de violation
des frontières orientales de l'otan et
de l'union européenne
je
vais enchaîner pour autant cette tournée
européenne de mateusz mort aviez ce qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité certains
observateurs estiment que le premier
ministre met l'accent sur la crise
migratoire pour cacher les violations de
l'état de droit en pologne en visite à
varsovie en milieu de semaine dernière
le commissaire européen à la justice
didier reynders a demandé des
explications de la part des autorités
polonaises
sous peine de sanctions ef est
spécifique de ce que
nous avons eu des discussions
spécifiques concernant la situation en
pologne et je dirais que la principale
préoccupation que nous avons en pologne
concerne l'indépendance du pouvoir
judiciaire car il ya un principe
important dans la façon d'analyser la
situation sur l'état de droit ce qui a
été décidé c'est de commencer par
quelques lettres de clarification
envoyées par les services mais pas par
l'introduction formelle d'un dossier au
conseil lui reprochent à la pologne de
ne pas appliquer une décision de la cour
de justice européenne demandant la
suppression d'une chambre disciplinaire
de la cour suprême varsovie est censée
payer un million d'euros par jour depuis
le 27 octobre pour le non respect de
cette décision vendredi dernier la
commission européenne a envoyé une
lettre à varsovie avant l'activation
éventuelle d'un mécanisme suspendant le
versement des fonds européens la pologne
a déposé un recours devant la cour de
justice européenne pour faire annuler
l'arrêté dans l'attenté de la décision
de la cjr la commission européenne n'a
toujours pas validé le plan de relance
polonais conditionné au respect de
l'état de droit et autres dossiers sur
la table des européens celui ci sur la
place qu'il devrait avoir au sein de de
l'otan joe maiden souhaite soutenir ses
alliés du vieux continent dans le
développement de leurs propres capacités
militaires la correspondance tout de
suite de thomas bonnin à washington
thomas par la voix d'un haut responsable
du département d'état le président
américain a appelé la nuit dernière les
dirigeants européens à passer de la
théorie à la pratique
oui c'est ce que explique ce conseiller
au sein du département d'état américain
dans une interview qu'il a accordée au
site politico interview au cours de
laquelle il affirme son soutien à cette
autonomie européenne en matière de
défense traduction concrète les pays
membres de l'union européenne doivent
dit il augmenter leurs dépenses
militaires au risque selon lui de voir
l'écart grandir entre les capacités
américaines et européennes autre aspect
évoqué dans cette interview un constat
qu'il a pu dresser ces dernières années
lors de très nombreuses réunions a
notamment à bruxelles où il a donc pu
constater un écart une différence entre
les paroles et les actes de la part des
ministres européens de la défense
écoutez le
j'ai assisté à énormément de réunion des
ministères de la défense quand je
travaillais au pentagone et quand
j'étais à bruxelles où tous les
ministres autour de la table étaient
d'accord sur la nécessité de dépenser
davantage en matière de défense mais
ensuite ce ministre de la défense devait
rentrer défendre ses budgets devant leur
parlement et leur gouvernement et il n'y
parvenait pas c'est une dynamique qui
existe encore aujourd'hui
derek cholet apporte donc son soutien à
cette demande d'autonomie européen en
expliquant que finalement washington
serait très heureux d'apporter des
solutions pour les capacités à
développer on comprend donc que les pays
de l'union européenne pourraient encore
être très lié très tributaires des états
unis ne serait ce que d'un point de vue
logistique voire même d'un point de vue
matériel alors cette interview s'inscrit
en réalité dans la lignée des prises de
position récentes de joe biden souvenez
vous après la crise diplomatique entre
paris et washington suite à la faire des
sous marins emmanuel macron avaient
voulu obtenir de son homologue américain
qu'ils soutiennent publiquement cette
initiative européenne en matière de
défense cela avait été le cas notamment
dans un communiqué qu'ils avaient été
publiés par les deux présidents à la
suite de leurs échanges mais malgré ce
soutien en apparence de la maison
blanche force est de constater qu'il
n'ya encore les mêmes réflexes américain
on avait déjà pu observer sous la
mandature de donald trump l'ancien
président qui je vous le rappelle
n'avait de cesse de demander aux pays
membres de l'otan d'augmenter la part de
leur budget alloué à la défense
merci thomas bonnet pour vos précisions
en direct donc de washington
amérique toujours mais but sud cette
fois avec le chili divisé au lendemain
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle josé antonio caste chef
de l'ultra droite est arrivé en tête
devant le candidat de la gauche radicale
à gabriel boric deux prétendants à la
succession du conservateur sebastian
pinera que tout oppose dans un pays en
crise en championnat
c'est un résultat qui symbolisent les
fractures du chili de candidats à
l'opposé l'un de l'autre sur l'échiquier
politique se sont qualifiés pour le
second tour des élections
présidentielles
d'un côté rossé antonio caste candidats
de l'ultra droite qui affiche sa
sympathie pour jaillir ball sonar au le
président brésilien et donald trump l'ex
dirigeant des etats-unis ses principales
propositions réduire l'immigration
illégale et la criminalité
le leader du parti républicain veut
maintenir le modèle néolibéral hérité de
la dictature de pinochet tout en
restaurant la sécurité
vive le chili nous allons travailler
pour établir la paix l'ordre le progrès
et notre liberté
à partir d'aujourd'hui chaque femme qui
ne peut pas rentrer chez elle
tranquillement à cause de la criminalité
et du harcèlement aura l'espoir de vivre
en paix
un candidat qui a vu sa cote de
popularité monter ces derniers mois une
période rythmée par des manifestations
violentes et par les crises sanitaires
et économiques autre favori gabriel
boric ancien leader étudiant est
candidat d'une coalition de gauche dont
font notamment partie les communistes
deux ans après le début d'un important
mouvement de contestation sociale
gabriel boric s'est appuyé sur un
électorat jeune en faisant campagne pour
une société plus égalitaire
seront confrontés à une seule décision
le 19 décembre soit nous nous dirigeons
vers un chili plus inclusif plus
généreux plus soucieux de son peuple où
nous ne laissons personne de côté
soit nous continuons dans la même
logique de rejet d'exclusion et de
privilèges contre laquelle le chili
s'est levé
le choix des chiliens de porter au
second tour deux candidats en dehors des
partis traditionnels symbolise une
volonté de changement un résultat inédit
dans un pays dirigé par des coalitions
de droite et de centre gauche depuis la
fin de la dictature
autre élection hier au venezuela
victoire écrasante du parti présidentiel
aux élections régionales le camp de
nicolás maduro remporte
unis 20 des 23 postes de gouverneurs
ainsi que la mairie de la capitale
caracas un scrutin marqué par le retour
de l'opposition ainsi que par la
présence d'observateurs internationaux
une première depuis 15 ans nicolas petit
les résultats sont tombés ce dimanche le
parti de nicolas maduro a remporté 20
des 23 régions y compris la capitale
caracas un scrutin aux allures de
plébiscite pour le président vénézuélien
héritier du chavisme qui avait appelé au
dialogue avant même le résultat final du
vote
ce qui émergera de cette élection sera
bien cela va renforcer le dialogue
politique renforcé la gouvernance
démocratique
renforcer notre capacité à faire face
aux problèmes à apporter des solutions
aux problèmes
griffures après les boycott de la
présidentielle 2018 et des législatives
2020 l'opposition qui a finalement
décidé de participer à ce scrutin avec
l'ambition d'impulser une nouvelle
dynamique pour la présidentielle
2024 n'obtient que trois régions alors
que le pays est confronté à une crise
économique sans pareil et à
l'hyperinflation
caracas qui espère la levée de sanctions
économiques notamment celles des états
unis au sujet du pétrole semblent
enclins à faire quelques concessions
habituellement à cheval sur sa
souveraineté le pouvoir en place a voulu
donner des gages de démocratie en
acceptant que ce scrutin soit observée
par l'union européenne une première
depuis 15 ans en tout 130 observateurs
ont été dépêchés avant le rapport
préliminaire sur le vote qui sera rendue
mardi la chef de la mission électorale
européenne s'est montrée rassurante
jusqu'à présent il ya eu des problèmes
concernant le vote qui ont été résolus
d'une manière ou d'une autre mais ce
sont des choses que nous aborderons plus
tard les nouvelles que nous avons sont
que les problèmes sont résolus
un bémol toutefois dans ce que maduro
souhaiterait présenter comme un
renouveau démocratique
le taux d'abstention très élevée au
total ce sont près de 59% des
vénézuéliens qui ne se sont pas rendus
aux urnes
restez sur arte france dans quelques
instants focus sur la politique agricole
commune à la veille du vote final des
eurodéputés à strasbourg dans notre
rubrique compense les français rencontre
d'un éleveur dans l'orne qui a subi de
plein fouet la baisse du cours de la
viande et la hausse des prix de
l'énergie il interpelle les politiques à
cinq mois de l'élection présidentielle a
tout de suite
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
vous
la communication des modèles mâcon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
pickton est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont il se désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus cooney sq justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour ça comme politique
personnelle est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
est dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
récemment le gouvernement français a
violemment réagi à l'annoncé d'un
mémorandum d'intention passé entre
wagner et le gouvernement malien la
france a été progressivement perçue est
considérée comme une armée d'occupation
qui protégeait les régimes en place au
mali mais aussi au tchad la france ne se
retire pas nés du mali du sahel s'agit
bien d'une transformation une
réorganisation ce ne sont plus les
militaires français forcément qui sont
en première ligne ce sont les militaires
maliens au regard de la situation
actuelle il est clair que nous avons
fait l'essai qui n'est pas falloir en
tirer les leçons et cesser de mettre sur
le compte de fée news ou campagne d'
influence le ressenti l'état d'esprit
des populations
si on ne veut pas se retrouver comme les
américains en afghanistan
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts ni
sur la bbc insu réalité et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
à l'heure de la coop 26 et d'un g20
particulièrement tourné sur le climat
comment répondre à nos besoins
énergétiques tout en prenant en compte
les défis environnementaux comme
d'habitude si vous voulez les coptes
sont des endroits où on fixe la date de
la prochaine coop les émissions de co2
n'ont jamais autant augmenté au niveau
mondial que depuis qu'on est celle été
abaissées aujourd'hui ma un espèce de
mots d'ordre qui est de fermer les
usines nucléaires mais sans penser à
comment on les remplace si demain on a
tous des voitures électriques on a pas
on n'a plus de voiture qui roule au
pétrole il va falloir qu'il y ait
beaucoup d'électricité produite et c'est
pas avec avec l'éolien pas d'énergie
parfaite on a été le premier importateur
mondial de gaz de schiste par contre
qu'est ce qu'on fait en france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années dont on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes
même si mort au maintien de l'ordre et
une catastrophe est tout à fait
déplorable on a vu des personnes
gravement blessées on a entendu aussi le
terme violences policières ce débat sur
les violences policières ce qu'il a
toujours existé il a toujours existé ou
la première grande manifestation
parisienne le 6 février 34 de même pu
craindre la disparition de la toute
jeune garde républicaine au mitan la
presse s'était déchaînée sur ce qu'était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
[Musique]
de retour sur rt france il est 21h très
heureux de vous retrouver pour la
deuxième partie d'émission au sommaire
une pac qui éthique chez les
agriculteurs
français à la veille du vote final des
députés européens sur la nouvelle
politique agricole commune 45
organisations un membre de l'association
un pack pour une autre papier de l'ufc
que choisir écrivains d'aujourd'hui au
premier ministre jean castex une lettre
ouverte pour alerter le chef du
gouvernement sur le fait que le texte
sous leurs yeux ne tient pas en compte
des recommandations scientifiques et des
attentes sociales en matière
d'environnement et de climat
[Musique]
les eurodéputés doivent donc adopté
demain en séance plénière à strasbourg
les règlements de la politique agricole
commune la réforme doit entrer en
vigueur en 2023 budget à disposition sur
sept ans à près de
390 milliards d'euros dont 70% des aides
directes aux agriculteurs pour certains
professionnels du secteur je cite la pac
est une usine à gaz nombre d'exploitants
dénonce la bureaucratie européenne entre
lenteur et aberrations les ong déplorent
de leur côté un texte qui manque
d'ambition en matière d'environnement et
de climat 45 organisations interprète
d'ailleurs à aujourd'hui le premier
ministre jean castex dans une lettre
ouverte
et on en parle avec nicolas giraud et
les porte parole de la confédération
paysanne
bonsoir nicolas giraud merci de répondre
à nos questions
demain c'est donc le vote ultime des
eurodéputés dans quel état d'esprit est
ce que vous êtes et dans quel état
d'esprit sont également vos confrères
mais on est on est assez dubitatif par
rapport à la tournure qu'a pu prendre la
politique agricole commune aussi bien au
niveau européen qu'au niveau français
c'est à dire que demain ce sera le
dernier vaut tenir au niveau européen
mais ce n'est pas encore totalement fini
c'est à dire que chaque état doit
rédiger son plan stratégique national
qu'elle commence à être rédigée par la
france et là jusqu'à la fin de l'année
pour l'envoyer à la commission
européenne et nous on attend deux du
gouvernement et du ministre de normandie
qui revoit à la hausse son plan
stratégique national parce qu'il prend
pas suffisamment en compte les enjeux
actuels qu'ils soient sociaux qu'ils
soient environnementaux ou qu'ils soient
alimentaires
il ya aussi le côté vert de cette
réforme les ong écologistes jugent que
le texte ne va pas suffisamment loin et
qu'il manque d'ambition quelle est votre
réaction
mais j'allais dire il ya bien ça c'est
une certitude déjà dire n'y a pas que
les ong qui met ça en lumière la cour
des comptes très récemment a pointé
l'inefficacité de la pac par rapport aux
enjeux écologiques et biodiversité
l'autorité environnementale qui doute
qui devaient évaluer le plan stratégique
national qui a commencé et et écrire et
qui a commencé à être écrit par le
ministère a relevé de graves lacunes en
termes d'environnement pour répondre et
à la crise climatique et à la perte de
biodiversité
donc c'est pas seulement des ong ou des
paysans qui remettent ça en cause c'est
toute une partie des personnalités qui
regardent la pac de près le coeur de la
réforme c'est de permettre à chaque et
un de répartir les deniers bon comme il
lui semble sur le territoire sans ré
sans réel contrôle bien loin de l'esprit
du projet est lancé en 62 c'est ce que a
déploré dans une tribune au monde
l'eurodéputé verts yannick jadot et
candidat écologiste à l'élection
présidentielle votre réaction
ma réaction c'est que de toute façon
de gouvernement en gouvernement de
politiques agricoles en politique
agricole commune on s'est beaucoup
éloignés des fondamentaux de la pac qui
était une pac alimentaire au départ est
le fondement de la politique agricole
commune au niveau européen c'est
l'objectif de sécuriser l'alimentation
pour l'ensemble des citoyens européens
c'est aussi l'objectif de sécuriser le
revenu du monde paysan et j'allais dire
sur les deux on est en échec les paysans
sont de moins en moins bien rémunérés un
bon paquet disparaissent en trente ans
on a perdu deux tiers des paysans est la
pac en a une responsabilité énorme et au
niveau alimentation on voit bien que la
crise sanitaire encore mis en lumière la
précarité alimentaire ne cesse
d'augmenter et
on peut bien se demander en quoi la
politique agricole commune pourrait
mieux répondre à ça et au lieu de
s'atteler à mieux répondre à ces enjeux
sociaux économiques et alimentaires le
ministre de l'agriculture
elle est l ensemble de la commission
européenne nous annonce une pac de la
stabilité c'est à dire que on va
continuer à voir les mêmes les mêmes
outils la même répartition les mêmes
équilibres qui sont pour nous
complètement déséquilibré pour le coup
avec presque
d'après ce que j'ai compris avec plus de
paperasse quand même d'après ce que j'ai
compris
voilà la paperasse est toujours le
quotidien j'allais dire du monde paysan
je ne sais pas si on aura plus haut
niveau au niveau de cette pac là après
on peut pas non plus
demander et j'allais dire à avoir une
des des subventions de la politique
agricole commune et de l'état français
sans avoir un minimum d'éléments à
pouvoir
répondre est justifié après il faut pas
que ça devienne quelque chose
d'absolument et non mais qui a peur les
le monde paysan au niveau de l'
enveloppe ses 387 milliards d'euros sur
sept ans dont
270 milliards d'êtres directes aux
agriculteurs c'est assez c'est pas assez
pourquoi
au niveau du volume financier j'allais
dire on est pas mal on peut toujours
être mieux mais les différents accords
qui ont été posées au niveau européen on
garantit une stabilisation de l'envelope
2 la politique agricole commune en
france c'est à peu près 9 milliards par
an qui arrive sur l'ensemble du monde
agricole c'est c'est globalement stable
mais après l'enjeu c'est surtout comment
est ce qu'on la répartie c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui en france 20% du monde
agricole 20 % des exploitations reçoit
55 % des z donc ça veut dire que c'est
c'est pas bien équilibré il ya toute une
partie du monde agricole notamment les
petites structures les petites fermes kg
skis et ne reçoivent rien ou très peu de
la pac vu que la pac est donnée à la
surface plus on a deux surfaces sur sa
ferme plus on aura touché deux
subventions de la politique agricole
commune même si sur sa ferme petites ou
grandes on répond à des enjeux sociaux à
des enjeux environnementaux ou
alimentaires finalement ça s'est
beaucoup moins a pris en compte que la
surface et comment l'améliorer parce que
le chiffre 20 % des gros agriculteurs
accapare 80 % des aides directes est ce
que ce que vous avez une proposition
nous clairement ça c'est déjà un petit
peu améliorée en france on est plus à 20
qui touche 80 on est à 20 qui touche 50
5 essais et c'est pour ça que le
ministre de la culture française se
cache là derrière en disant on fait déjà
mieux que l'ensemble de la commission
européenne va pas encore aller plus loin
nous sommes nous semble être une grave
erreur et pour arriver à faire mieux au
niveau social il ya trois mesures toute
simple la première c'est de plafonner
les aides nous à la confédération
paysanne on revendique que au delà de
45000 euros dead parents et pas actif
paysans on arrête les subventions ça
c'est la première mesure la deuxième
mesure c'est une aide aux petites et
moyennes femmes c'est à dire que on est
un forfait qui soient dissociées
finalement de la surface pour les fermes
qui sont petit pour arriver à mieux les
soutenir et à donner l'impulsion pour
que plus de paysannes et paysans plus
s'installer et la troisième mesure c'est
une majoration des aides sur les 52
premiers hectares qui est déjà en place
dans la réforme actuelle mais un niveau
insuffisant tout ça c'est des mécanismes
qui aurait pu être mis en place dans
dans le plan stratégique national
français
le cadre européen elle permettait
aujourd'hui le ministre a choisi de
n'activer aucun de ces leviers la de
redistribution merci nicolas giraud
d'avoir répondu à une question je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
de la confédération paysanne
les agriculteurs français mécontents des
mécontents d'un côté mais aussi des
éleveurs de l'autre qui se sentent
incompris dans notre rubrique compense
les français qui ment aussi à didier
mulot sont allés à la rencontre de
maxime vaugeois dans l'orne cet
exploitant a subi de plein fouet la
baisse du cours de la viande bovine il
ya quelques mois aujourd'hui c'est la
hausse des prix de l'énergie qui impacte
son activité à cinq mois des élections
présidentielles il interpelle les
politiques
juillet à elle ménage dans l'orne en
normandie où je viens rencontrer maxime
vaugeois les éleveurs de bovins et il va
nous présenter son exploitation alors
montré le petit peu qu est ce que vous
avez comme belgacom comme comme bovins
donc là ici on est sur une case de
jeunes bovins à l'engraissement donc
c'est des animaux de race charolaise pas
réussi salaire si si c'est des animaux
qu'on élève pendant 12 mois sur la ferme
et qui sont abattus avant l'âge de 24
ans l'année dernière on a connu une très
mauvaise année si on parle uniquement
prix de la viande on aimerait un cours
autour des 4 euros sauf que l'année
dernière on a fait à peu près 6 8 mois à
3 euros 60 donc là c'est pas tenable je
pense qu'aujourd'hui tout est à peu près
à la normale et donc on a appris du jb
qui a dépassé les 4 euros depuis un mois
et demi voilà on en est content
aujourd'hui on voit un petit peu plus
cher mais nos charges ont beaucoup
augmenté tout ce qui colle la sauge a
fortement augmenté depuis un an est
également tout ce qui va être en grève
donc tous les engrais sont aujourd'hui
très cher parce que ça suit le cours du
pétrole bien sûr et donc il ya de la ja
déjà une difficulté d'approvisionnement
en engrais et des prix qui vont être
très élevées pour la saison prochaine
j'attends pas forcément énorme grand
chose des présidentielles en tout cas au
niveau agricole c'est jamais facile de
cerner un candidat savoir s'il sera
soutenir au bon moment la production
d'antennes en a besoin trouver un
candidat qui sera répondra à tous les
moules l'agriculture fin les mots et
babx de l'agriculture aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué enfin il n'a pas forcément la
réponse la décision à prendre sur le
consommateur final sur le prix de vente
de nos produits si effectivement cette
tendance de manger moins de viande cette
volonté des consommateurs de ne plus
voir d'animaux à l'intérieur des
bâtiments devient une majorité de la
population eh bien peut-être qu'on fera
évoluer notre système peut être qu'on
produira la viande différemment peut
être qu'on produira plus de viande si
effectivement il n'en faut plus comment
ça pourrait se mettre en place et ce que
ça veut dire que si vous divisez votre
exploitation donc de maître par 2 par 3
est ce que c'est les prix dans ce cas là
qui va être augmentée ce qu'il faudrait
taxer est ce qu'il faudrait imposer un
quota tout simplement par personne si
vous me dites que je préférais qui est
moitié moins d'animaux par case et ben
parce que comme ça il aura un meilleur
confort etc ou qu'ils aient des parcs
extérieurs etc moi je vais vous répondre
bah c'est plus de travail donc il faut
que j'embauche quelqu'un mais il faut
que ça passe a demandé par une
rémunération supplémentaire les charges
de mécanisation énormément augmenté
parce que la ferraille ou manque de bois
augmentons par les tares de construction
de nouveaux bâtiments aujourd'hui et
construire un nouveau bâtiment a pris
30% tout ça c'est aussi des choses qu'on
doit pouvoir répercuter un moment donné
sur le prix de l'eau prix de l'autre le
plus gros reproche que j'ai à faire au
consommateur c'est identifier l'origine
des produits enfin moi j'ai énormément
de gens et pourtant des gens du milieu
rural que je côtoie quand je regarde ce
qu'ils mettent parfois dans leur frigo
mais je l'aimé rendez vous qu'on vous
avait été acheté un truc qui vient de
l'autre bout du monde qu'il faut avouer
que le consommateur il sache vraiment ce
qu'il veut moi quand on parle d'écologie
effectivement que les gens font même pas
attention à ce qu'ils achètent et d'où
ça vient et quel impact carbone ça eh
ben je me dis qu'on est l'info et que le
consommateur il se il se voit les yeux
et il se dit je vais demander aux autres
de faire mieux par contre moi je fais
pas forcément attention à ce que je fais
quoi les éleveurs français tout comme
les agriculteurs veulent donc faire
entendre leur voix à la proche de
l'élection présidentielle la france
peut-elle redevenir la première
puissance européenne dans le secteur
agricole les agriculteurs français
peuvent-ils mieux vivre de leur métier
celle face à face
[Musique]
et sur ce plateau philippe bourrier achi
vous êtes conseiller
régional europe ecologie les verts en
ile de france face à vous il y avait 100
baladi conseiller municipal les
républicains à la mairie de paris
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être présent
sur ce plateau on vient de voir maxime
vous joie au micro de guimard aussi un
éleveur qui a exposé ses difficultés il
ya beaucoup d'agriculteurs d'éleveurs
qui ont du mal alors qu'on la dit à la
politique agricole commune la réforme va
être votée finale demain avec les
eurodéputés restera debout à strasbourg
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de lui
répondre à maxime vaugeois filet
brouillage qui lui répondent la chose
très simple nous les écologistes nous ne
détestons pas les aviculteurs où les
paysans contraire nous les aimons et
d'ailleurs benoît biteau qui est un
paysan est sur la liste des européennes
de yannick jadot et le monsieur conseil
agriculture paysanne de yannick jadot
effectivement et la raison comment ils
font pour vivre aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs les paysans qui sont
prisonniers de la nef soeur ils sont
prisonniers de cette pac qui vous
obligent à augmenter la surface et donc
à être les esclaves de l'agroalimentaire
sion des multinationales nous nous
proposons de rediriger la pac est
différemment aujourd'hui 75% de ces deux
grands piliers de la pac sur ces fameux
10 milliards sont destinés uniquement
sur les grandes
concessions et donc forcément ces
agriculteurs sont obligés de s'endetter
et rentre dans une spirale infernale et
vous savez que 40 % des agriculteurs ce
pays à peine 350 euros le mois vous avez
un suicide tous les deux jours et ça ça
ne peut plus continuer on ne peut pas
congeler des poulets pour les envoyer en
au brésil et défaut reste l amazonie
pour faire du soja pour nourrir nos
bovins il faut de la viande de bonne
qualité qui vit dans des conditions et
qui grandit soient élevés dans des
conditions dignes et par le passé comme
ces fameux ferme millevaches et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut réorienter la pac
vers tous ceux et toutes celles qui font
un effort considérable pour répondre aux
normes sanitaires qui répondent aux
normes écologiques ils soient pas si on
m'y arrêter la quantité et privilégier
la qualité complètement votre votre
réponse à maxime vaugeois qu'on a vu
également au micro de guy marosi qu'est
ce que vous lui répondez vous vincent
baladi j'ai écouté d'agriculteurs alors
ce qui nous a dit c'est que tout
augmente est par exemple il parlait de
construction tout augmente et la pac
n'augmentent pas alors certes même si on
retranche le royaume uni où on note une
légère augmentation donc sur les six
années mais par contre quand on regarde
dans le détail avec l'inflation c'est
une baisse de 10% de la pac donc
concrètement de nos agriculteurs vont
continuer à mourir de faim vont
continuer à avoir des problèmes il y
aura encore des suicides c'est
malheureux je rappelle que la pac aura
50 ans l'année prochaine que c'est aussi
un héritage des pères fondateurs
aussi de nous de notre famille politique
en tout cas de droite on est très
attaché à la pac bien évidemment il faut
plus d'écologie il faut plus d'éco
responsabilité
mais consommé un légume qui vient je
rappelle qu'un légume sur deux vient de
l'étranger pour moi c'est pas du tout
écologique
justement les écologistes en tous les
cas les associations écologistes
demandent à ce que le texte aille plus
loin en matière d'environnement et de
climat
les français ce qu'ils sont prêts à
accepter le coup j'ai envie de dire le
coût en termes de prix alors qu'on parle
tout le temps dans cette campagne
présidentielle du pouvoir d'achat est ce
qu'ils ont les moyens de mettre plus
cher pour manger mieux car vraiment
c'est sûr que si on le présente comme ça
je ne connais pas un citoyen qui vous
avez vous je veux payer plus et quand on
regarde ce qu'on a dans le portefeuille
on en a pas beaucoup donc c'est pas
possible de leur présenter comme ça faut
juste
réorienter
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure un
produit sur deux vient de l'étranger
alors que nous avons les capacités
aujourd'hui ici et là je pars des
patates mais en mange des chips
c'est vraiment avoir des chips là c'est
vraiment le monde à l'envers -
simplement on peut produire ici on peut
produire local privilégier les circuits
courts donc larron on enlève tout ce qui
est frais transport ça fait du bien pour
la planète parce que du coup il ya moins
d'effet de gaz à effet de serre mais
surtout surtout ça réduit les coûts et
puis comme je vous le disais nous les
écologistes demain nous ne voterons pas
le texte en l'état parce qu'il est juste
une amie il continue à précariser les
aviculteurs il continue à frapper les
consommateurs de manière sanitaire parce
que lorsque vous voulez produire en
masse vous n'avez pas le choix
aujourd'hui la fnsea et le plus grand
représentant des lobbys de 2,2 de
produits phyto dit sanitaire mais c'est
des voix là on est on est bien d'accord
que lorsque vous mettez du glyphosate
vous savez ce qui va venir derrière et
en plus les premiers riffs is ce sont
les agriculteurs etc des premiers
victimes de ces produits là donc c'est
pour une question de santé publique
nous devons sortir de ce modèle là et
donc par conséquent réorienter les aides
vers toutes celles et tous ceux qui
produisent de manière écologique et bio
en agriculture bio par les fameux label
que nous avons fait le gouvernement et
monsieur de normandie qui est ne veulent
surtout rien changer c'est pour ça que
le problème de cette pâte de laisser les
gouvernements donc en gros la fnsea
décider à qui elles attribuent les
subventions met en péril l'agriculteur
et le paysan qu'on a vu juste avant elle
aimait réellement perella les met en
danger nos donc nous nous proposons de
rééquilibrer sa de mettre des moyens
vers celles et ceux qui veulent
produire de bonnes qualités produire
locaux regardez le fameux scandale du
triangle de gonesse on voulait
construire europa city sur des terres
agricoles pour nourrir sur lesquels on
peut nourrir les franciliens enfin le
monde marche à l'envers nous on devrait
juste le remettre à l'endroit et on va
aller avec benoît biteau avec telly
jadot expliqué tout ceci est tout cela
aux agriculteurs et aux paysans et leur
dire que nous ne soit pas leur ennemi
nous sommes dans meilleur allié vincent
maladie moi je voulais juste à l'arrière
sur ça parce que moi quand je vois les
mairies divers gauche dont dont des
membres écologistes parce que je vois
c'est qu'en ile-de-france ya de plus en
plus de bétonisation
et et malheureusement on sucre si j'ose
dire un petit à petit ses exploitations
agricoles donc faites ce que je dis
faites pas ce que je fais moi je suis
totalement pour effectivement les
exploitations agricoles je rappelle
aussi que la stratégie en france depuis
plus de 50 ans c'était la stratégie
aussi dans un contexte mondial ça veut
dire que général de gaulle
et tout ce qui a été fait derrière que
c'était de passer d'augmenter les
structures parcellaire et
d'augmenter la force agricole française
avec des structures plus grandes de
rentrer dans le xxème siècle puis dans
le 21e siècle la question aujourd'hui
c'est quelle est la stratégie de la
france surtout que cette pac elle va
donner plus de poids à la france aussi
dans la stratégie et c'est ça un peu
qu'il fait peur aujourd'hui avec le
gouvernement français puisque le
gouvernement français malheureusement
aujourd'hui en tout cas avec le
gouvernement des bagnoles macro il
réagit et il agit pas du tout que c'est
jari réagit à tout ce qui se passe on
est dans un contexte mondial la france
et est troisième ex pote exportateur
mondial elle est passée sixième voire 7e
en agriculture il réagit mais n'agit pas
mais vous feriez quoi comment vous
feriez pour agir mais nous on ferait on
ferait concrètement si vous voulez on
augmenterait notamment l'aide sur la pac
on ferait de la transition en douceur
quand on voit par exemple qu'on nous
parle des pêcheurs on le dit oui il faut
supprimer il faut le matériel des
pêcheurs se fait si l'on pût les dix ans
c'est pas normal c'est anti écologique
par exemple donc nous on agirait
concrètement on a des députés à
l'assemblée nationale comme julien dive
qui ont des vues qui ont fait des
propositions concrètes vous pouvez aller
voir sur le site des républicains sur
l'agriculture on est le parti quand même
crédible aussi sur tous ces sujets tout
en mêlant l'écologie
il ya aussi la hausse du gasoil on l'a
entendu cet agriculteur maxime bourgeois
c'est 10 à 15000 euros de surcoût par an
est ce que l'état survient
suffisamment pour pouvoir protéger ses
agriculteurs on voit bien une démission
totale du gouvernement macro et et
monsieur je viens de normandie qui fige
vraiment je suis pas sûr que tous les
agriculteurs et les paysans connaissent
ils les pêcheurs les éleveurs connaît ce
qui est leur ministre de tutelle là on
parle vous parlez du gouvernement actuel
mais quand cette question c'était plus
sur l'ensemble quand je disais à l'état
la politique agricole commune existe
depuis depuis bien longtemps il ya eu
des politiques de gauche et de droite
dans l'ensemble est ce que l'état sur
dix avouent l'a dit il y avait de gauche
et de droite mais il n'y a jamais eu
aujourd'hui est que nos politiques
écologistes et c'est pour ça qu'il est
agréable et dynamique je ne vivrai pas
jusqu'à
nous souhaitons nous souhaitons une
politique réellement réaliste est qui et
qui englobent la totalité vous savez
lorsque vous êtes un éleveur ou vous
êtes un paysan où vous êtes un citoyen
lorsque vous allez à la pompe et que
vous payez de la tva sur des taxes là on
se dit en marche à l'envers alors c'est
sûr qu'il faut non simplement aider les
agriculteurs font leur permettre de
pouvoir passer sur des mécanismes
différents et beaucoup enfin et moins
énergivores sauf qu'aujourd'hui il y à
des lobbys qui imposent leur diktat et
vous voyez très bien que ce gouvernement
est aux mains des lobbys et lobby au
doigt et à l'oeil le bouton sur la
couture de celles et ceux qui ont qui
peuvent les aider à tout point de vue sa
maladie oui enfin moi je pense
les galim concrètement nous imposent de
plus en plus de bio dans les cantines
mais c'est pas du bio forcément français
c'est ça qui est décevant sur loin par
exemple je siège est à une commission
dans notre mairie d'arrondissement dans
le viiie
concrètement on nous dit qu'on peut pas
favoriser les entreprises parisiennes
franciliens loup française c'est pas
normal du tout on est dans un contexte
mondial il ya une concurrence
internationale et c'est là où le ou la
france et l'europe ne veut pas faire
tout le temps de d'angélisme abbès où je
ne peux pas faire d'angélisme mais
simplement faudrait savoir si nos
gouvernants ont le courage d'imposer les
normes parce que c'est vrai que lorsque
les normes sanitaires les normes
européennes où les normes mondiales met
en concurrence les uns et les autres et
surtout lorsque nous en français on est
les bons élèves là-dessus lorsqu'on
sommet tout de suite immédiatement donc
ça entraîne des surcoûts pour nos
éleveurs alors qu'en face avec je pense
de ce parent taffetas setao mercosur
nous ne jouons pas avec les mêmes règles
donc on joue sur un terrain de foot
certains ont le ballon et nous on l'a
pas sauf qu'on a des équipements dernier
cri qui nous empêche ça veut dire que
faire du protectionnisme oui le le le le
pack vert européen
va dans ce sens là
vous pouvez pas demander aux éleveurs
français de respecter les normes
sanitaires pour le bien-être de toute la
population et puis en attendant recevoir
du boeuf élevé aux hormones aux ogm qui
vient du canada ou qui vient du brésil
nous qui sommes d'argent qui enfin c'est
pas réaliste donc il nous faut des gens
à tête du gouvernement comme les ninjas
dos des gens qui sont capables de taper
du poing sur la table non ça c'est pas
possible soit mais contre c'est là où
l'europe a un vrai enjeu c'est là où
l'europe à 27 à un vrai poids si on part
chacun dans notre sens et dans son sens
à mon unique et la pac actuelle qui va
être votée j'espère qu'elle sera pas
voté mais il y donne le plein pouvoir au
pays dits acp les gens moi je vous
regardez ce qui s'est passé en hongrie
on a pu mitchell c'est juste scandaleux
et donc là on a un exemple il faut gros
pas du tout reproduire cet exemple sur
les 27 vous dites justement qu'à 27 il
faut se mettre d'accord les italiens les
syndicats de travailleurs italiens eux
veulent signer des deux mains cette
cette pac
oui parce qu'il ya tout un volet social
effectivement dans cette pac veut dire
fermez pas me faire dans cette pac après
il faut être très réaliste ni à 27 c'est
quand même compliqué ah bah oui enfin je
dirais maintenant à 26 je crois avec le
royaume uni en moins enfin enfin moi ce
que je pense vraiment c'est que il faut
vraiment qu'on se mettre tous autour
d'une table écologistes droite centriste
et c est qu on trouve une solution au
niveau européen cette pac effectivement
je vois que ça quand même fait avancer
le bien-être animal l'écologie c'est un
point fort alors je sais pas si mon si
mon collègue doit être d'accord mais en
tout cas enfin moi ce que je vois c'est
que c'est quand même bien maintenant il
faut qu'on aille plus loin et qu'on
réfléchisse encore une fois une
stratégie sur le long terme et
malheureusement comme ça a été fait
d'ailleurs en place à l'est sur sept ans
c'est pas le long terme 7 6 en 2021 et
2027 effectivement c'est pour ça qu'il
faut agir maintenant parce que là ça
nous engage pendant six ans et on peut
pas faire machine arrière on ne peut pas
se permettre de perdre six ans
supplémentaires c'est pas possible et y
compris pour les paysans les éleveurs
moi je le répète
yannick jadot les écologistes nous ne
sommes pas les ennemis d adultère nous
sommes effectivement les ennemis du
racing quand même pas forcément de vous
mais on parle beaucoup de la ghriba
chine dont on parle beaucoup de bien sur
deux choses comme ça et on en parle ne
le fait pas lorsque nous nous le ferons
on dit ce qu'on fait on fait ce qu'on
dit les choses sont bien claires le
virage il faut le prendre maintenant on
ne peut pas se permettre de perdre
encore cinq années de plus et je le
redis et c'est vraiment
c'est pas malheureux j'ai entendu le mot
made out alors c'est pas malheureux ne
sert un drame tous les deux jours un
paysan un éleveur à l'agriculteur temps
tout met fin à sa vie 40 % des
agriculteurs des éleveurs des paysans
gagnent moins de 350 euros par mois
alors qu'il travaille 70 heures par
semaine c'est pas possible on doit aller
les aider on doit aller leur rescousse
deux ans doit entendre leur cri de
détresse c'est maintenant qu'il faut
agir et nous c'est ce que nous proposons
le mot de la fin pour vous vincent
baladier pas moi je dis malgré la pac
alors si on supprime la pac je pense
qu'ils seront encore dans une situation
bien plus compliquée donc moi je suis
pour cette pac pour maintenant
génération de la pâte la pac en l'état
actuel qui laisse me c'est pas compliqué
s'approcher de profiter à des systèmes
mafieux en hongrie en république tchèque
donc si vous laisser les états décider
juste et juste le mot de la fin c'est
qu'il faut aussi se comparer par rapport
aux autres pays européens il faut pas
oublier que l'allemagne ou les pays bas
produisent énormément en servent
aujourd'hui c'est plus forcément en
pleine terre comme en france il faut se
réinventer mais que ça soit écologique
et sur ce point je pense que nous sommes
d'accord merci vincent maladie d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes conseiller municipal et l'air
à paris mais également philippe boyer
achi d'avoir répondu à nos questions
vous êtes conseiller municipal europe
écologie général concile m6 passe en
régionale en ile de france europe
écologie les verts
avant de nous quitter je vous rappelle
notre appel à témoins vous êtes
agriculteurs ou éleveurs et vous voulez
nous faire part de vos difficultés au
quotidien ne vous at on aussi à
lapproche d'élection présidentielle
écrivez nous à l'adresse qui s'affiche
sur votre récompense les français c'est
la fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi rendez vous demain dès 20 heures
mais si la n'oubliez pas de réagir et de
commenter de poser vos questions sur le
télégramme de rt france prochain point
sur l'information d'ici une trentaine de
minutes avec pierre pissavy yvernault
bonne soirée à tous obèses
mais
[Musique]
récemment le gouvernement français a
violemment réagi à l'annoncé d'un
mémorandum d'intention passé entre
wagner et le gouvernement malien la
france a été progressivement perçue est
considérée comme une armée d'occupation
qui protégeait les régimes en place au
mali mais aussi au tchad la france ne se
retire pas ni du mali du sahel s'agit
bien d'une transformation une
réorganisation ce ne sont plus les
militaires français forcément qu'ils
sont aux premières lignes ce sont les
militaires maliens au regard de la
situation actuelle il est clair que nous
avons fait l'essai il va falloir en
tirer les leçons et cesser de mettre sur
le conte de fées news ou campagne d'
influence le ressenti est l'état
d'esprit des populations
si on ne veut pas se retrouver comme les
américains en afghanistan
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes mais ce qui nous alertent nous
c'est la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui est gay accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
soit son diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention et à l'aide
d'un système très curatif 1 c'est
essentiel d'avoir l'information pour pas
subir
bonjour bienvenue dans ses cages